Welcome back.
Let me erase what I did.
And I should have done this
before starting this.
But it doesn't take too long.
We're on problem number 6.
And once again, a figure that
has not been drawn to scale.
They do that to you
on purpose.
Sometimes it is drawn to scale
and they say that it's not.
You shouldn't assume anything.
And they're saying that this is
3x degrees, they say that
this is 2x degrees, and they say
that this is 4x degrees.
In the figure above, three line
segments meet at a point
to form three angles.
What is the value of x?
Well, what are all of these
angles going to
have to add up to?
If you add this angle plus this
angle plus this angle,
what do you do?
You went all around
the circle.
So they have to add
up to 360 degrees.
So 2x plus 4x plus 3x is going
to equal 360 degrees.
And what's 2 plus 4 plus 3?
That's 9x.
Let me see.
This is always where
I mess up.
2 plus 4 is 6, 6 plus 3 is 9.
9x is equal to 360.
x is equal to 360
divided by 9.
It equals 40.
And that is choice C.
Problem number 7.
Positive integers x, y, and
z-- so they're integers--
satisfy the equations x to the
minus 1/2 is equal to 1/3, y
to the z is equal to 16.
OK, those are the
two equations.
If z is greater than y, what
is the value of x plus z?
So the trick is-- because you're
saying, well, how do I
solve for this?
Well, the trick is that
you know that
these are all integers.
So first of all,
let's do this.
So x to the minus 1/2
is equal to 1/3.
That means that 1 over the
square root of x-- I just
rewrote x to the minus 1/2.
1/2 power is square
root, and the
negative means the inverse.
So 1 over the square root
of x is equal to 1/3.
Or you could say the square
root of x is equal to 3.
x is equal to 9.
So that was easy.
We just solve this.
You just have to know that a
negative means to invert, and
that 1/2 power is the same
thing as square root.
Now y to the z equals 16.
We've got to come up with
integers y and z where is z is
greater than y that
end up at 16.
Well, the number that
immediately pops out is 2 to
the fourth power.
2 to the fourth power
is equal to 16.
The other option was 4 to the
second power, soon. right?
But 4 to the second power
wouldn't have satisfied this,
because 4 is greater than 2.
So the exponent has to be
greater than the base.
So 2 to the fourth.
And we know that because
it has to be integers.
So we know that z
is equal to 4.
So what's 4 plus 9?
It's 13.
x plus z.
13.
And that is choice D.
Next problem.
I'm on problem number 8.
And let me draw what
they have drawn.
I don't even know if it's useful
for me to draw, but I
will do it because
they've done it.
And then they have
a semicircle.
So I could do a semicircle,
something like this.
I could draw it-- use the
circle tool like that.
Roughly.
That's good enough.
I could erase the bottom if I
wanted to, but let's just
assume that we only
see this top part.
And they say-- whoops, I'm still
using the line tool.
This point is 4 comma 0.
This point is 8 comma 0.
And they say, in the semicircle
above, the center
is at 4 comma 0.
Which of the following are
x-coordinates of two points on
the semicircle whose
y-coordinates are equal?
Well, this is an interesting
question.
Because it's not so much math,
but it really is getting the
intuition of kind of the
symmetry of the circle.
So it wants to know two
points on the circle
where the y is equal.
So, for example, this point
and this point.
The y is going to be equal.
And so it would be this
point and this point.
And similarly, we could say,
well, this point and this
point, the y's are equal.
If we take down, it would be
this point and this point.
The key is any of these pairs of
points have to be the exact
same distance from the center.
And that makes sense.
If we go the same distance to
the left and go up to the
circle, and we go the same
distance to the right and go
up to the circle, they're going
to intersect the y-axis
at the same point.
So we have to look at their
choices and see which of their
pairs of choices are equal
distance from x equals 4.
So the first choice
is 1 and 6.
1 is 3 less than 4, and
6 is 2 more than 4, so
that doesn't work.
A is 1 and 6, and that doesn't
work because 6 is much closer
to 4 than 1 is.
B is choices 1 and 8.
Well, 1 is 3 away from 4.
Right?
1 is here.
Well, 8 is all the way here.
So 8 is 4 more than 4.
3 you less, 4 more.
Doesn't work.
C.
2 and 6.
This looks promising.
2 is 2 less than 4.
6 is 2 more than 4.
So that's 2 less, bam, it's
going to be there.
2 more, bam.
Going to be there.
So that's our answer.
We don't even have to look
at the other ones.
But if you look at the other
ones, you'll see that they're
all different distances
away from x equals 4.
Next problem, problem
number 9.
If p is an integer, and 3 is
the remainder when-- OK, so
let me write this. p integer.
3 is remainder when 2p plus
7 is divided by 5.
3 is the remainder.
Then p could be-- well, there's
a bunch of ways you
could do it, but really the
simplest way, the very
simplest way, is to just
try out the numbers.
And let me ask you a question.
When you divide something by 5,
if you get a remainder of
3, what is that number going
to have to end in?
Well, it's going to end
in a 0 or 5, right?
Oh, sorry.
It's going to end
in a 3 or an 8.
Because if something is
divisible by 5, it ends
with a 0 or a 5.
5, 10, 15, 20, 25.
All of these are
divisible by 5.
And if you add 3 to any of these
numbers-- 8, 13, 18, 23,
28, and so on, 33-- all of these
numbers are going to
have a remainder of 3 when
you divide by 5.
And then you could also say,
well, any of these numbers is
going to be the numerator.
And then you can actually,
if you want, you
could subtract 7.
But actually, we
won't do that.
What we could do is just try out
the different choices they
give, and see if any of these
choices create a number that
ends in an 8 or a 3.
So let's see.
Choice A is 2.
What is 2 times 2 plus 7?
It's 4 plus 7 which is 11.
It's not that one because
it ends with a 1.
B.
3.
3 times 2 is 6.
6 plus 7 is 13.
We're done.
And you can try it out.
If p is 3, 2 times 3 is 6.
Plus 7, 13.
Divided by 5.
Well, the remainder is going to
be-- it's 2, remainder 3.
So it works.
And that was it.
And it's good.
We didn't have to waste time
figuring out C, D, and E.
OK.
And then-- oh, I only
have a minute left.
So I will wait to do the next
problem in the next video.
See